les propositions législatives de la
commission européenne dans le domaine de
la fiscalité le président jean claude
juncker s'est félicité de son bilan lors
d'un passage en belgique cette
commission dit il a soumis au conseil et
au parlement plus de propositions en la
matière que n'importe quel autre
commission antérieur alors combien la
commission juncker a t'elle soumis deux
propositions toutes matières confondues
l'actuelle commission européenne a fait
949 proposition au parlement et au
conseil européen depuis son entrée en
fonction en novembre 2014 mais
retireront tout ce qui se rapporte à la
migration la santé la mobilité ou encore
l'environnement pour ne finalement gardé
que la fiscalité au sens le plus large
nous obtenons 93 proposition législative
alors est ce mieux que tout autre
commission et bien si l'on remonte dans
le temps jusqu'à la première équipe de
commissaires présidé par walter
hallstein on voit que la fiscalité
n'avait pas le même poids ou la même
importance
il faut attendre les équipes de jacques
delors pour voir un sursaut des
propositions fiscales
mais c'est à la commission de romano
prodi que l'on doit le plus important
nombre avec pas moins de 159 texte
proposé soit bien mieux que l'actuelle
commission alors pourquoi jean claude
juncker se permet-il cette affirmation
est bien difficile à dire car pour
l'instant sur le seul critère de
quantité il n'y a qu'en réduisant le
champ aux textes liés à l'évasion et
l'optimisation fiscale que l'on parvient
à peine à faire remonter sa commission
sur le podium
là l'équipe juncker a fait 18
propositions ce qui la place juste
derrière son prédécesseur josé manuel
barroso
avantage revient uniquement à une guerre
d'un point de vue proportionnelle ramené
au nombre de propositions par 100 jours
de mandat cela fait une proposition
réguler 6 et là c'est un fait
personne n'a encore fait mieux dans
l'histoire de la commission barroso ii
deuxième est à un texte véhicules 16 sur
l'évasion par 100 jours de présidence
reste qu'en termes absolu dire que
l'équipe juncker a soumis le plus de
propositions législatives sur la
fiscalité
[Musique]